>> Tucker: JULIAN ASSANGE HAS
BEEN IN JAIL FOR AN AWFULLY LONG
TIME.
HE’S NOW IN JAIL IN THE U.K.
HE WAS UNDER HOUSE ARREST IN A
FOREIGN EMBASSY IN LONDON.
THE U.S. HAS NO ACCUSED JULIAN
ASSANGE OF VIOLATING THE
ESPIONAGE ACT.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR A
LONG TIME, AND IT TOOK US A VERY
LONG TIME COMING YEARS TO ASK
THE OBVIOUS QUESTION.
WHAT EXACTLY DID JULIAN ASSANGE
DO WRONG?
ALL GOOD PEOPLE HATE JULIAN
ASSANGE.
WHAT WAS HIS CRIME EXACTLY?
WAS HE HACKING INTO OTHER
PEOPLES COMPUTERS, WAS HE
STEALING SECRETS FROM THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT?
NO, HE WAS A JOURNALIST, HE WAS
AN EDITOR, THAT IS LITERALLY
TRUE.
DO YOU THROW EDITORS IN JAIL
BECAUSE THEY EMBARRASS YOU?
PROBABLY SHOULDN’T, NOT A GOOD
PRESIDENT TO SET EVEN IF YOU
DON’T LIKE THE PERSON’S
POLITICS, YOU SHOULD BE AGAINST
THAT.
WHY A GROUP OF PEOPLE ARE
AGAINST HIM, WE RECENTLY SPOKE
TO PAMELA ANDERSON WHO IS TRYING
TO GET A PARDON FOR ASSANGE.
>> THIS IS ONE OF THOSE MOMENTS
IN HISTORY AND IN HIS LIFETIME
IS ALSO WHERE WE NEED TO MAKE
THE RIGHT DECISION.
IT WAS ALL UP TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE REALLY CAN’T
A HUGE FOLLOWING AT A HUGE SIGH
OF RELIEF AND GRATEFULNESS FOR
SO MANY PEOPLE ON THE PLANET.
>> Tucker: WE SPOKE TO ROGER
WATERS OF PINK FLOYD ABOUT IT.
TONIGHT WE WILL SPEAK TO JULIAN
ASSANGE’S FATHER AND BROTHER.
JOHN IS HIS FATHER, GABRIEL IS
HIS BROTHER, WE ARE HAPPY TO
HAVE THEM ON THE SHOW TONIGHT
FOR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: THIS IS A SINCERE
QUESTION, WHAT DID YOUR SON TO
WRONG EXACTLY?
WHAT IS HIS SPECIFIC CRIME?
>> WELL, NO SPECIFIC CRIME AT
ALL, TUCKER.
IT’S JUST OFFENDED SOME PEOPLE
IN CERTAIN SECTIONS OF
WASHINGTON AND CONSEQUENTLY HAS
FACED 12 YEARS NOW OF
PERSECUTION AND HARASSMENT.
JULIAN, AS YOU KNOW, IS NOT AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN.
YET HE’S BEEN TRIED UNDER THE
1917 ESPIONAGE ACT TO BRING
JULIAN TO THE UNITED STATES
UNDER THE THREAT OF 175 YEARS IN
JAIL.
NOTHING AT ALL, JUST EMBARRASSED
A FEW PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: FOR THOSE OF US IN
THE BUSINESS OF EMBARRASSING AND
OFFENDING PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON,
THIS IS A BAD PRECEDENT, LET’S
BE HONEST, WHICH IS ONE OF THE
REASONS I’M INTERESTED IN THIS
CASE.
GABRIEL, TELL US THE CONDITIONS
YOUR BROTHER IS IN RIGHT NOW.
CAN YOU GO SEE HIM IF YOU WANT?
>> HE’S IN BELMONT PRISON.
I VISITED HIM IN OCTOBER LAST
YEAR AND SINCE THEN, HE HAS BEEN
IN TOTAL LOCKDOWN DUE TO COVID
SO HE HAS HAD NO VISITORS FROM
ANY FAMILY OR HIS LAWYERS, SO HE
IS IN A MAXIMUM SECURITY PRISON,
SO ALL THE MOST DANGEROUS
PRISONERS FROM AROUND THE U.K.,
THE MOST VIOLENT PRISONERS, AND
HE HAS BEEN THERE UP ON THREE
YEARS NOW.
HE WON HIS EXTRADITION CASE ON
JANUARY 4TH AND THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT APPEALED AND A COUPLE
DAYS LATER HE WAS REFUSED BAIL.
SINCE JANUARY, HE’S BEEN SITTING
IN PRISON, AND THEN ASCEND MAN,
NOT ABLE TO SEE HIS FAMILY OR
LAWYERS, AND WE JUST DON’T KNOW
WHEN THE APPEAL WILL HAPPEN OR
WHEN THIS WILL END.
>> Tucker: NOT ONLY IN A CENT,
I DON’T EVEN THINK THE CHARGES
MAKE ANY SENSE AGAINST HIM.
IN THIS COUNTRY, YOU ARE
CONSTITUTIONALLY ALLOWED, IT IS
THE FIRST PART OF OUR
BILL OF RIGHTS, THE
FIRST AMENDMENT, YOU ARE ALLOWED
TO PRINT THINGS THE GOVERNMENT
DOESN’T LIKE, WHICH IS WHAT HE
DID.
LET ME ASK YOU, IS ANY AMERICAN
ELECTED OFFICIAL, I KNOW THERE
ARE ACTIVIST TYPES AND CABLE
NEWS HOSTS, BUT AS ANY ELECTED
OFFICIAL TAKING YOUR SIDE ON
THIS?
>> NOT SINCE BIDEN’S
INAUGURATION, NOT SINCE
PRESIDENT BIDEN’S INAUGURATION,
25TH OF JANUARY, WE HAVEN’T
HAD -- IT’S BEEN SILENT FROM
PEOPLE IN CONGRESS AND THE
SENATE, WHICH IS PART OF THE
REASON WHY WE ARE DOING THIS, IS
TO ENCOURAGE AMERICANS TO STAND
UP FOR THEIR FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS.
AND SPEAK TO THEIR
CONGRESSPEOPLE AND TELL THEM
THAT AN ESPIONAGE ACT,
PROSECUTION --
>> GO ON?
>> Tucker: I THINK WE ARE
HAVING SOME AUDIO PROBLEMS BUT
LET ME FINISH HER SENTENCE, AN
ESPIONAGE ACT, PROSECUTION FOR
HIM PRINTING THINGS THE
GOVERNMENT DOESN’T WANT HIM TO
PRINT.
IT’S GOING TO COME BACK AND BITE
US IN THE BUTT AND WE SHOULD NOT